de nombreux secteurs vont se mobiliser
ce mercredi 15 mars contre la réforme
des retraites et les Yvelines seront
impactés dans les transports la RATP
s'attend un trafic perturbé sur les RER
et recommande le télétravail il faudra
s'armer de patience sur les quais 3 rera
sur 4 circuleuront mercredi
l'interconnexion sur un maintenu à
Nanterre Préfecture pour le RER B et C
compter 2 trains sur 3 en circulation le
trafic sera également perturbé sur les
trains de la région parisienne il y aura
trois trains sur 4 sur la ligne N il y
aura deux trains sur 3 pour la ligne J
et l le trafic sera quant à lui normal
sur la ligne U pour les bus le trafic
devrait être quasi normal dans les
Yvelines du côté de l'enseignement des
perturbations sont attendues dans les
écoles les collèges et les lycées mais
aussi dans les accueils périscolaires et
les services de cantine